is weird thanks
yeah I love a good bite man I love a
good bite a good sandwich and you get
that like okay previously you bit down
so now you got two like mouth corners
and then you just get that triangle bite
yeah
you hit that with the dip oh oh that'd
be ranching you boys dipping well I'm
doing dips like dip yes
like in a lip excuse me
two different podcasts
yeah
the Chipotle you're requesting the
garlic spicy mayo there we go there we
go there we go you guys are dippers
[Music]
like green two right here
I already saluted him yeah yeah I'm
dipping yeah yeah I'm different damn but
we get criticized man and crucified
sometimes man for difference amount of
dips that we realize
okay
it's actually a problem you guys ever
get the Cajun Chicken Little is that
cheesecake no the what the Cajun chicken
littles a Cheesecake Factory
yeah someone is saying yes my [__]
occasion chicken little chicken it's
like tenders and a bunch of fries or you
can swap the sides out but the best
thing is the dips they have Buffalo
Ranch blue cheese barbecue honey mustard
ketchup this is awesome
I'm telling you but one time this guy
just got I could tell he's getting
frustrated with how many lines he was
making this notepad you flip the sheet
just on sauces so I knew it had a
saucepan yeah he had the sauce pager and
he forgot one
which one the honey mustard uh
[Laughter]
I forgot that's it and forget the
difference
[Laughter]
I brought you ten so you forgot the most
important one good I asked for a living
yeah yeah I'm just laughing at him like
like walking away like he's he thinks he
has your order and you're like no no
player you turn them around and you flip
his paper back you're like you forgot
the sauce page
[Laughter]
I got a Diet Coke and then I'll get a
honey mustard and ranch and barbecue
sauce ketchup it's like okay I think
that's it and then you pull out your
sandwich
[Laughter]
yeah
yo sometimes you gotta blend products
man yeah because sometimes like Wingstop
got the wings yeah yeah
that's that's my latest what uh Wingstop
and then pizza from the other place you
ever happened to meet up at the doorstep
and chicken yeah we had a la link up the
other night oh wow trust me
yeah Papa John's is pulling up to my
curb listen the pizza ain't said he said
it
Pizza didn't say the N word
the pie is good and how high is it man I
probably
the fight made me say the n words like
damn [__] this [__] is good
so they they took me to this spot in
Toronto and I have to be honest I was
afraid
to order that's right well because these
guys know food so I don't want to [__]
it up and uh I did [__] it up because I
went and got a shitty coffee on the way
to the place and Trey's like this place
has the best coffee man I was like oh
okay I walked in there with my shitty
ass coffee
this trade's like hey man you gotta junk
that it's disrespectful
so you were to the to the to the rest
for the store yeah they really do coffee
should he have ordered from I should
have just not brought that [__] bro that
[__] coffee yeah is he going out and
got his own coffee pickup yeah yeah it
was like garbage Hotel coffee I felt
like my dad was yelling at me like
but then proceeded to have one of the
craziest meals of my life what was the
meal Egyptian style Egyptian Blends yeah
I can't even say it that's the thing
every time people ask me about this this
restaurant coffee or Egyptian food what
is Egyptian food
see the good stuff yeah
man I always have trouble with the
actual like ones
it's like oh yeah yeah
Egyptian brunch and it's a long story on
How I Met these guys it's a family that
runs it the son he makes the coffees
that's why I was introduced to it the
the sister and the mother in the kitchen
cook it and they're crazy it's just a
bunch of Egyptian spices Meats
marinations
very authentic yeah and you go in there
you forget about outside you lick you go
outside you're like oh [__] wait what am
I doing today they treat you such like
family in there so it's more of an
experience to like go eat and food's
good coffee's good you leave you're like
all right now let them say the N word
all day yeah they can man
[Laughter]
white kids
lining up to work at the restaurant like
yo Jay and Trey said if I can cook like
you I get a pass yeah
who's that oh yeah there it is that's a
movie look at that I forgot what they
call that man this is the crazy chicken
sandwich oh that looks good mind-blowing
chicken a lot of dips and flavors and
that's a lot of dips right there yeah
he just sort of dips on you and this
came off search up dips real quick man
who got the dips in the city bro we made
a place introduced dip a pizza joint oh
my God
man take him back we're certified demons
man I I like food you know what I mean
and I like knowing food spots when my
friends come to town like yo you want
pizza you were you're just in town I
said yo do you want pizza sent to your
room right now I threat and do it yeah
let me be very clear let me very clear
Trey is threatened me with a pizza party
he's threatening me with a haircut okay
he's threatened me with clothing these
sound like awesome threats yeah no
they're great yeah yeah I want to make
sure my people can I get on your bad
side
yeah
showing up at your door right yeah don't
[__] trade man he's gonna [__]
he's gonna ruin your life with a pizza
party what's the pizza place uh it's
called makers Pizza in Toronto and we've
been going there for a long time uh and
the first time we went in there uh
Jermaine and I ordered a pie and we're
like okay so pepperoni pie and then I'm
looking at the menu I'm like and then
I'll just I don't see it but I'll just
take three Ranch tips and turn around
they say oh no no we don't have dips
what the [__]
our pizza don't need this actually you
actually threatening them yeah we're
keeping them from another place
so I said all right no fine whatever
they said we do our pizza does not need
dip no dips not any story that's the
same face I made right there we can
Replay that face that was me at that
pizza so I said all right whatever
walk down the street and go get some
Diana sauce I come back
over the pizza box squirt my sauce and I
have a good time this is Diana sauce in
the cold by the way yeah man you forgot
we got craft wrench I did it we did have
the ranch you got a bottle yeah yeah
yeah
it really is there's a beautiful from
Kentucky right now like yeah yeah
put him in the holster and yeah I just
told him I'm like yo man you really need
like ranch with this it's just it just
makes sense and then we kept in contact
you know throughout throughout the years
and then uh he hit me up he said
actually all night it's a menu
it's a section and they didn't just do
regular dip like they did a CR what is
that creamy garlic what wow Parmesan
Parmesan Dill buttermilk ranch they went
crazy but they DM me and they're like yo
listen we're working on the sauce we
need to send it to you to try it I said
all right since we're like 15 pizzas we
approved these dips I approved yeah I
may own a project
[Laughter]
in Toronto